hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round three of this
year's charge of Masters you guys
requested it as soon as it finished and
for very good reasons it's a very short
game and it shows uh that even though
sometimes we can play a game like Grand
Masters do although not not as often
sometimes Grandmasters play a game like
we do and you guys were probably
expecting the game from board one uh
pregnant is playing women's world
champion Juve engine uh but that game
ended in a draw fairly quickly okay now
this quickly as this one ended but
fairly quickly and
um I wasn't really an exciting game it
was pretty much a snooze Fest so they
played excellent chess but it's not
something to uh to uh you know enjoy uh
that being said let's check out this one
it is lucasfan 4S versus Harsha
baratakoti let's see what happened in
this one as Lucas has the white pieces
and he opens with E4 we have C5 by uh
Harsha uh going for the Sicilian Defense
and now C3 the all up in variation and
usually uh D5 will be played here and
it's a very standard way and you know
when when you teach children chess you
you tell them okay when C3 is played the
C3 square is no longer it's no longer
possible to occupy the C3 square with
the Knights you don't mind playing D5
and then if captures let's say queen
captures you don't have Knight to C3 and
your queen can uh stay on D5 for the for
the moment so you don't have to worry
about the wasting early Tempe but here
we have Knight to F6 it's also a a very
nice line but it runs into a very very
forced variation so Pawn to E5 Knight to
D5 we have pawned the four characters
captures and now Pawn to D6 sometimes
Pawn the E6 is played first but both
moves will be played Knight to F3 we
have E6 and Bishop to C4 so this is what
I've been seen before many many times
Bishop D7 uh both players castle and now
Queen to E2 we have D captures and E5
this is now a fairly rare move uh
usually just a B6 and you continue
development or A6 or Knight to D7 but
capturing an E5 this early is quite rare
here we have the characters on E5 and
now Bishop to D7 uh Rook to D1 nicely
aligning The Rook with the queen on d8
and the bishop to C6 now and
interestingly there is a game uh from
2019 youth World Championship uh where
uh pregnant played also this position
with the black pieces he played against
yachty slow zarubitsky and Prague in
that game is robitski played Bishop to
D2 Prague won a very nice game but here
we have Knights the D4 uh deviating from
that game and also Knight to D4 is the
top move recommended by the engine so I
don't know if Lucas is still in his
preparation here or not but okay Bishop
to C5 and now comes Knight captures on
C6 here uh it seems I've I've checked
how you should play this it seems like
it's a sorry not that fairly equal equal
line let's say Knight to C3 Queen to B6
now you don't have to worry about Knight
A4 as the bishop is guarding that and
now the Knight on D4 is saying let's say
queen G4 now defending and also
preparing Bishop to H6 and now you would
wanna get the the White Queen away from
the defense of the night there okay
lights the queen to H4 Knights the D7
you continue development and now
everything gets traded off Bishop
capture C captures Knight B3 attacks the
bishop you don't have to worry about F2
that's nicely guarded now D4
uh Knight captures and see five Queen
captures and now grabbing the pawn with
Rook captures on E5 and black wins the
pawn back with queen or Knight captures
on E5 so everything gets traded down uh
black has this um well expansion on the
king side with his H Pawn March forward
but you know everything should be uh
should should be okay at some point
maybe even Queen G5 offering a queen
trade maybe white wants to go for the
attack so this is how the variation uh
should be played but in the game we have
Knight captures and C6 and this now uh
tends to complicate the matters a little
bit we have Knight captures on C6 Bishop
to D2 and now Bishop to D4 and okay
Bishop to D2 was played with the idea of
a country in the bishop to D4 move with
Bishop to C3 so Bishop captures and C3
and now you have to play Knight captures
and C3 you absolutely have to play this
and um then it's sort of okay Knight
captures on C3 Knight captures now the
queen is hanging with checks you do not
you do not have the option of playing
Rook capture Sandy eight so you'd have
to play B captures C3 now the queen
moves and now something like F4 you get
this position where black will always be
better it's um uh okay white has this
very nice expansion here he controls E6
he controls F6 uh he might even uh try
and get the Rooks into the game but it's
very hard to imagine that this becomes
possible Rook is coming to d8 and then
black is just perfectly fine if anything
this uh will be a weakness and white
does have the isolated ANC pawns if the
position trades down into an end game
but instead uh uh he didn't go for
Knight captures on C3 Lucas went for a
sufficient too he played the in-between
Bishop captures and D5 and this uh
completely blunders the game for a very
specific reason so feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out why this
is so uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
only one defending that B2 Pawn is the
queen and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Knight to D4 uh
this is what uh hashabara played and it
was in this position on move 16 uh that
lucasfan Flores resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the queen is hanging and all of these
squares are taken by the bishop and by
the Knight so if you if you move the
queen let's say then just Bishop
captures on B2 and you don't have a good
reply to this you could even try to
complicate a little bit let's say Bishop
captures Rook attacks Bishop Basham goes
back somewhere well it's a bishop before
you can even attack the H7 Pawn but the
problem is after Bishop captures on A1
there's just nothing for white here even
if you play Bishop captures on H7 King
h8 you don't have a queen to H3 it it
might even be okay if you had a queen H3
but here it just runs into uh this a
very nice Knights the E2 check and
that's it you get checkmated on the next
move uh regardless of what you play so
that's kind of the issue and another
thing after Knight to D4 even if you
don't play Queen to D3 you might think
okay let's give up the exchange we could
continue the game at least uh not really
there there's no counter play for
example uh after Bishop captures you
will see some like Bishop to F3 getting
the bishop to safety now Queen B6
putting more pressure on the B2 pawn and
after the Knight defense you just bring
more Firepower to the C3 Knight the
Knight cannot move you cannot defend or
you could try to defending the Playbook
to C1 then Rook the C5 then the E5 Pawn
hangs and the white will just be more
down more and more material and I mean
there's no point in continuing there's
nothing to hold on to so it's just a a
terrible blunder and after Knight to D4
the best thing you can do is resign and
maybe save your energy for for the next
day uh so yeah like I said sometimes you
guys will play like a grand master but
sometimes the Grand Master makes a
mistake that uh you know you guys would
make and it's normal because okay it
seems that nowadays in modern times that
these mistake things happen or more
often than they did let's say 20 years
ago but it's just that today so much
chess is being played there are so many
tournaments going on simultaneously um
in the world so many games are being
played and of course uh more blunders
will occur and since you know we we
people are like that we usually like to
hone in on those blunders and enjoy them
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a lot of games still being
played in the Chargers Masters if you
guys have a favorite do use hashtag
suggestion I will go over your
suggestion and if I I if I think the the
others will enjoy our suggestion I will
show that game uh so yeah thank you for
watching I would like to thank David
Kimura black terrano uh Peter Martin of
AMD risen Enthusiast group and
golfsoftware.com for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament and checking up any
wonderful suggestions uh as they are are
you really quite wonderful so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day